bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau 7,8 week-end comme tous
les vendredis nous allons revenir sur
les moments forts de l'actu port loisirs
et culture de la semaine pendant 26
minutes
au cours de cette émission nous
parlerons gourmandise en cette fin
d'automne avec la directrice divine
tourisme sylvie la ona qui m'a déjà
rejoint sur le plateau et puis vous
découvrirez certainement saint quentin
en yvelines
comme vous ne l'avez jamais vu grâce au
photographe francis tac
mais tout d'abord à un peu moins d'un
mois de noël j'imagine que vous devez
être en pleine recherche d'idées de
cadeaux pour vos proches et bien dans
kiosque aurélien de bissy vous en donne
quelques unes que vous pourrez trouver
sur les marchés de noël à saint quentin
en yvelines et notamment à montigny le
bretonneux
les festivités démarrent dès ce vendredi
et jusqu'à lundi donc ces trois jours de
festivités à la ferme du manège alors
pendant ces trois jours elvire de
meredith nous qu'est ce qu'on va pouvoir
trouver comme stand est ce qu'il ya des
originalités des nouveautés cette année
chaque année il ya des nouveautés au
marché de noël on a à peu près 100 à 120
exposants répartis entre un marché
alimentaire qui se trouve dans la cour
de la ferme du manège où se situe le
marché de noël est une grosse à peu près
une centaine d'exposants à l'intérieur
de la grange ou qui présente à peu près
tout ce qu'on peut imaginer en matière
de cadeaux ça va des cadeaux en bois de
la peinture des cadeaux en céramique eu
des décorations de noël
des du textile je trouve des produits
locaux des artisans bien sûr qu'on
trouve des propos on ne peut pas faire
un marché de noël sont rendre hommage
aux commerçants de la ville est
également villes jumelles qui sont avec
nous pour ce marché
c'est ça puisque des délégations
d'allemagne d'italie d'irlande et
d'angleterre
un second où les allées marines seront
donc présents donc on aura donc des
idées de cadeaux aux provenances aussi
de ces pays
vous parliez de producteurs locaux
effectivement on en a une illustration
avec vous franck de gosse puisque alors
vous c'est votre vingtième participation
on peut le rappeler le marché de noël
donc de montigny-le-bretonneux inaugure
salle inaugure comment dire sa 21e année
fête ses vingt ans exactement alors
franck de gosses ou vous exposez donc
depuis ça sera votre vingtième année
pour vous qu'est ce que ça représente
finalement ce marché c'est une vitrine
supplémentaire
d'accord mais est ce que vous y
rechercher quelque chose de particulier
une clientèle nouvelle c'est l'occasion
pour proposer des nouveaux produits
en fait on expose toujours le au marché
de noël de montigny c'est surtout pour
faire de la communication montrer nos
produits que nous fabriquons à
montigny-le-bretonneux
et puis oui c'est surtout voir de voir
nos clients et puis être toujours voir
nos clients habituels et puis est
toujours là haut
au rendez-vous du marché de l'eau est ce
que c'est l'occasion peut-être de
répondre à des commandes spéciales
en fait nous proposons notre carte de
noël de fêtes de fin d'année est souvent
les clients prennent le comment de
pointe déjà la carte pour pouvoir
commander après comme nous faisons une
journée portes ouvertes le 14 décembre
on en profite pour donner des cartes et
après il vient de passer commande
chaque année les recettes qu'elle est là
la tendance cette année en fait nous
avons créé trois nouvelles bûches de
noël
et puis nous avons créé aussi des petits
bâtonnets des ce qui me choque qu'on
appelle ça va on a fait aussi pour le
nous avons créé ces battant chocolatées
pour aussi le marché de noël de montigny
j'en parlais en début d'émission nous
allons parler gourmandise aujourd'hui
avec civile à onna qui m'a rejoint
bonjour à vous bonjour vous êtes saison
que la directrice individus tourisme je
le rappelle pour nos téléspectateurs et
on continue à parler de goodies
aujourd'hui et de gourmandise et donc
c'est ce week end la clôture de notre
événement goût divine au domaine de la
corniche harold oise et là on va pouvoir
découvrir des démonstrations ateliers
donc ça veut dire qu'on va pouvoir
tester la réalisation de recettes salées
sucrées et ensuite les déguster donc ça
c'est plutôt intéressant on découvre la
façon de les faire et on les mange
et puis il y aura des producteurs du
terroir qui seront là aussi donc on
pourra acheter quelques produits pour
noël
donc ça c'est et good yvelines dans sa
partie clôture mais ne pas oublier
surtout que good yvelines à la base
c'était aussi des restaurateurs
yvelinois qui proposait des menus du
terroir donc à base de produits locaux
une entrée un plat un dessert donc on
avait une vingtaine de restaurateurs qui
proposait ses menus et donc c'est à base
de
liqueurs du noyau de poissy de fromage
de chefs de la ferme des toits des trois
ponts de volailles de là quoique et tri
de la ferme de la coke et prix de
confiture d'andrésy j'en passe et des
meilleurs donc ne pas oublier que c'est
le dernier week-end pour en profiter
parce qu'après c'est fini et ça montre
bien qu'il ya beaucoup de produits du
terroir dans les yvelines
absolument et c'est parce qu'on pense
puisqu'on est un département d'île de
france et on n'a pas tendance à penser
qu'on a tout ça dans les yvelines
eh bien si et donc ça en est la preuve
les yvelinois pourront eux aussi
déguster les plats incontournables du
côté de marly-le-roi pour le en
prévision déjà des îles de loos fait
donc on découvrira l'historique un petit
peu des plats spécifiques que l'on peut
déguster en période de l'avent jusqu'à
l'épiphanie donc la bûche de noël la
galette des rois les treize desserts
donc au découvrira un peu toutes ces
traditions de cette période de l'année
dans le monde entier grâce à l'office de
tourisme du pays des impressionnistes et
pour ceux qui ont loupé le beaujolais
nouveau
le lieu est toute trouvée puisque il y
encore quelques bandes anges dans le
département oui ce sont les vendanges
tardives de saint germain en laye et
pour célébrer un peu tous à l'office de
tourisme de saint germain va nous
proposer des conférences projections où
l'on va découvrir les origines de la
vigne et du vin
et puis on va te le tueur et cette
petite conférence par une dégustation du
vin des grottes le vin de saint germain
en laye donc ça c'est assez festif
encore une fois et donc ensuite on peut
aussi faire autre chose que déguster du
vin puisque c'est habré célébration des
cocktails au trianon palace à versailles
et vous allez apprendre à devenir le roi
de la soirée en réalisant des cocktails
à base de jus de fruits aromatisées et
donc vous serez le véritable tom cruise
dans cocktail à l'issue de cette
fabuleuse expérience au sein d'un
établissement de luxe du département
j'ai coché d'ailleurs je crois que la
dégustation de cocktails au trianon sera
un de mes premiers choix à un moins d'un
moins d'un mois de noël je le disais
tout à l'heure dans les tripes dans les
titres pardon il y aura aussi de quoi
préparer les fêtes de fin d'année
évidemment mais oui et puis s'amuser
aussi puisque nous avons des communes
qui nous ont organisé des patinoires
puisque qui dit hiver dit souvent froid
patin à glace donc à versailles près du
château et de l'hôtel de ville donc nous
avons une patinoire écologique
tout ça c'est à partir du 4 décembre et
puis à rambouillet a également place
félix faure il ya une vraie patinoire de
glace là cette fois ci où on va pouvoir
peut-être faire ses premiers patins ou
alors se perfectionner donc dès le 4
décembre
il ya aussi la fête du conte un petit
peu plus près sur saint quentin en
yvelines même alors la fête du conte
c'est pour faire en sorte que les
enfants forgent leur esprit développent
leur imagination à l'aspect conte de
noël essayé l'office de tourisme de
saint quentin qui nous propose cette
animation pendant les périodes de noël
et puis si les téléspectateurs n'ont pas
encore trouvé leurs cadeaux ils pourront
encore se rendre sur certains marchés
voilà alors le marché est un marché un
peu spécial parce que c'est le marché de
noël de la boutique oberkampf qui ce qui
se situe dans le musée de la toile de
jouy à jouy en josas
et là on peut faire ses achats de noël
achats arts de la table ou alors
décorations de noël au motif de la toile
de jouy que tout le monde connaît qui
sont de plus en plus à la mode
d'ailleurs
et puis pour terminer cette chronique
évidemment pas des décorations parce
qu'il faut bientôt préparer le sapin et
c'est à la maison alors à la ferme de
gally il ya tout un tas d'animations qui
sont proposées et notamment dans la
boutique de la ferme de gally on peut
acheter ces décorations de noël
et puis aussi décorer sa maison
pas que son sapin sa maison achetée
plein d'objets dans cette jolie boutique
qui a également une partie restaurant où
on peut consommer tout en faisant ses
achats et puis c'est la visite du père
noël évidemment à gali il sera là on
pourra le rencontrer les parents les
enfants pourront venir le voir et en
chair et en os
le père noël à gali faut pas l'oublier
et puis à bas le fan en l'ambassadeur du
père noël parce que le vrai on ne voit
jamais c'est moi c'est que ces
ambassadeurs convoi et donc il ya aussi
des ateliers
il y en a plein à galié de différentes
sortes confiant en a pour tous les goûts
on peut abri apprendre à fabriquer des
cadres à base de laine aux couleurs de
noël tout un programme
et puis on peut fabriquer des cartes de
voeux aussi et plus pour les enfants un
petit peu original on va apprendre à
faire des empreintes d'animaux de la
crèche de noël
si c'est pas original de quoi voir toute
une panoplie pour les fêtes merci
beaucoup
sylvie de votre venue sur le site
week-end pions son niveau en quinze
jours pour les fêtes de noël
précisément c'est bien ça à bientôt à
bientôt c'est désormais devenu un rendez
vous incontournable pour les passionnés
d'histoire
la sixième édition du salon histoire de
lire s'est tenue ce week-end à
versailles l'occasion de côtoyer des
auteurs très connus comme l'euro deutsch
maxime est venue de créteil pour
rencontrer son idole lorànt deutsch qui
a présenté au salon du livre d'histoire
de versailles ses derniers livres
hexagonaux moi je suis l histoire de
pitch tout petit donc je continue comme
ça oui et franck ferrand aussi beaucoup
de monde pour saluer cet auteur
populaire venu animer une conférence sur
le thème la france quelle histoire on
dit souvent quand à lire est un succès
que c'est du chiffre mais c'est surtout
des visages et là on voit les visages on
voit pas tes chiffres
moi ce que j'essaie de faire comprendre
c'est que lille s'est pas justement pour
un public averti ou de la littérature
c'est notre réalité géographique c'est
notre réalité
nous avons une histoire et cette
histoire là se déroulent sous nos pieds
pour peu qu'on s'y intéresse un tout
petit peu donc voilà j'essaie de
captiver les gens autour de quelque
chose qui est rassembleur mais que c'est
l'histoire qui nous appartient à tous
j'apprécie la façon qu'ils travaillent
pour l'histoire de france
là on la rendant dynamique accessible on
lui redonnera un nouveau souffle
je suis très sensible que j'avais mon
chum grande passionnée d'histoire et ça
me fait ça fait vraiment plaisir de voir
le
l'élan autour de l'histoire dans les
allées du salon d'autres visages connus
nelson monfort n'est pas seulement
commentateur sportif
il est aussi l'auteur d'un ouvrage sur
les grands événements sportifs du 20e
siècle
je pense c'est un public à la fois
averti et nombreux et moi c'est
exactement ce que j'aime j'aime aller
vers les gens absolument on écrit pour
être lu sinon ça sert à rien il faut
sortir des des cénacles et des lieux
confinés
en fait j'ai fait des rencontres
extraordinaires sincèrement et peut-être
que des rencontres qui vont avoir des
répercussions parce que intel m'a dit
qu'il avait des archives extrêmement
intéressante sur un sujet qui pourrait
m'intéresser pour un prochain livre
en tout le salon histoire de lire aura
accueilli pendant ces deux jours 125
hauteur et près de 10000 livres proposés
à la dédicace je le disais dans les
titres de cette émission vous allez
découvrir grâce à la nouvelle oeuvre de
francis tac le photographe bas fonds
saint quentin en yvelines sous un autre
angle et sous tous ses angles france
ithaque bonjour merci de nous avoir
rejoints
combien de temps vous avez mis à faire
cet ouvrage photographique sur saint
quentin en yvelines
ce nouvel ouvrage vingt ans après
l'ouvragé saint quentin en yvelines qui
m'avait été demandé donc en en 93 j'ai
mis dix mois pour faire les images c'est
à dire que ça m'a été confié en
septembre 2012 et toutes les images ont
été faites dans l'intervalle de temps
entre septembre et juillet 2013 rien
vous le disiez vous avez biais déjà
auparavant il ya 20 ans réalisé ce type
d'ouvragé en 20 ans est ce que la
communauté d'agglomération a beaucoup
évolué je pense que la volonté politique
de montrer à saint-quentin nouveau se
heurter à la réalité à savoir que il ya
eu quelques modifications dans la ville
mais les grosses structures ont été
définis il ya une vingtaine d'années
donc ya pas eu de manière significative
des modifications importantes et le
challenge s'était montrée justement
autre chose que ce qu'il fut montré une
vingtaine d'années
donc on vous avait fait alors du coup
pour vous adapter à cette petite
évolution j'ai si j'ose dire
binger j'ai passé beaucoup de temps j ai
pris j'ai pris beaucoup de plaisir
j'aime le challenge est et quand on sait
qu'entre le 1er janvier 2013 et la fin
avril il ya dû y avoir quatre jours de
soleil dans cette période donc ce fut
pas toujours très simple mais je suis
persévérant et est systématiquement je
tournai
autour de mes sujets jusqu'à trouver les
circonstances favorables il est clair
que le printemps par exemple fut bref
plus vieux donc systématiquement si vous
voulez j'ai cherché dans la ville les
les couleurs les couleurs du printemps
et je pense avoir réussi une approche
poétique différente de ce qui avait été
fait donc dans le passé à l'origine nous
n'avions pas d'idée préconçue sur le
cheminement de deux ouvrages mais au fur
et à mesure des images qui fut qui
furent faites on a structuré
donc ce livre en sept chapitres mais
c'est essentiellement un regard poétique
fonction sur la ville à travers la
nature ses oeuvres d'art et les gens qui
travaillent des gens qui apprennent oui
moi ce qui m'a surpris en feuilletant
baba ce très beau livre c'est vous
parliez de saison c'est qu'on voit
beaucoup de photos divergent montrée
peut-être deux à la caméra voilà ça
c'est ce sont deux photos prises pendant
l'hiver et il ya beaucoup de photos de
neige en fin de compte donc c'est
souvent les paysages les plus peut-être
difficile à photographier à capturer non
non pas du tout on peut y avoir des
hivers sans neige
on a été servi dans les premiers mois de
l'année donc comme j'avais pas mal de
temps cette année il est clair que il ya
certains sujets qui se prêtait
particulièrement aux épisodes neigeux
mais bon je suis même pas certain qu'ils
équipent plus de 6 images sur 120 de la
neige en livres par rapport à votre
technique justement comment vous
saisissez toutes ces belles images
vous appréhendez comment l'environnement
qui vous entourent j'ai une passion pour
la lumière et la couleur
donc c'est une quête permanente de cette
couleur c'est pour cela que j'insiste
sur la qualité de la lumière en disant
que quand il fait gris généralement je
fais pas d'image néanmoins et l'image de
couverture de ce nouveau de ce nouveau
livre donc la teste à cet endroit on y
est passé des centaines de fois des
milliers de fois et par le plus grand
des hasards
un jour je suis tombé donc sur quelqu'un
qui était en train d'expérimenter une
maquette hydrofoil au coeur du bassin
voyez c'est une image de spontané j'ai
pas j'ai pas amener l'acteur qui s'est
trompé dans sous l'arche de co2 kowalski
et une dernière question il ya t'il une
photo qui vous tient peut-être un peu
plus à coeur dans ses 120 clichés y en a
beaucoup que j'aime donc cette photo de
couverture j'en suis assez satisfait il
ya une autre image assez anecdotique qui
est peut-être celle ci cette image on
voit le le vélo devant ce récit fait
assez étonnante parce qu'on
on comprend leur montrer à la caméra
expliquez-nous un petit peu cette
histoire de voile à deux de ces baies la
cité c'était à l'occasion donc de la
fête du golf à saint quentin dans le
centre de montigny vous pourrit pouvez
expérimenter donc vos talents de golfeur
et à côté du bassin de marta pan sur
montigny
on y avait mis un cadre il à terre que
le graffeur nous on est en train de
peindre donc il y a il a pas les quatre
faces de ce cube toute la journée et je
cherchais le sujet si vous voulez donc
le photographier et au fur et à mesure
de la journée dont qui s'est passé
différents événements jusqu'à ce que
donc je finisse par partir et je prends
ma voiture je m'en vais et la seule que
je vois toute une équipe de type déguisé
sur le bord de la route et c'était
c'était les gens de de la boutique de
voisins-le-bretonneux des dix addict qui
faisait leur promo dans le sens d'un sac
de 50 alors je l'immédiatement je
descends à leur dis faites moi le tour
du cube
donc je commence à les photographier
mais vous aviez un style des filières
déguisé en paon d'or je ne sais quoi
filialiser tous déguisés de manière un
petit peu folklo et le cycliste en
l'occurrence est venu voir l'image il
m'a dit très bien mais je veux en faire
une je vais sauter plus haut et puis il
est repassé il s'est mis en équilibre
sur la roue arrière il a sauté à noyers
c'est aussi simple que ça très bien
merci beaucoup francis m c'est sur le
site week-end je le rappelle donc voila
ce nouveau livre saint quentin en
yvelines en images et avec des textes de
paul jean mary merci encore à l'office
de tourisme 2
laisser cette chance merci beaucoup
offrant cistac à très bientôt peut-être
pour de nouveaux clichés merci certains
de vos collègues d'ailleurs exposer
leurs réalisations ce week-end à
neauphle-le-château pascal crew est
photographe professionnel
il tire ses clichés des cadeaux du
hasard rencontre avec un artiste qui
laisse la nature venir dans son objectif
on est du côté de ben toujours dans les
yvelines une photo qu'à une petite
histoire parce qu'en plus de ça elle
avait été primé dans un concours et
c'est jean jacques aillagon ailleurs
qu'ils m'avaient armée le prix en
question c'était dans l'est dans les
jardins du château de versailles et je
me rappelle que c'était à un moment
c'est sympa c'est une photo qui était
prise à côté de ben en fait pareil et
tout à fait par hasard
pour pascal crowe est pas de mise en
scène dans ses clichés la bienveillance
du hasard est au coeur de sa démarche
artistique
je fais partie des photographes un peu
feignant j'attends que le hasard bosse
pour moi beaucoup c'est le cas aussi
tout un tas de photos j'ai fait ou je me
suis trouvé de tête au bon endroit au
bon moment
j'appuie sur le déclencheur et puis
après je travaille un petit peu dessus
en post traitement comme beaucoup
aujourd'hui de manière à pouvoir avoir
la photo mais je la cherche pas
spécialement
donc j'ai pas de techniques appropriées
j'ai pas vraiment de recette le fruit du
hasard est vraiment un vrai conflit
sport ou en tout cas cette année dix
neuf artistes passionnés de création
photographique se sont réunis à neauphle
le château à l'occasion du salon des
photographes
organisée tous les ans la deuxième
quinzaine de novembre par le syndicat
d'initiative
cette huitième édition poursuit sa
tradition de diversité des genres et
mélange des techniques un regard sur le
monde
un point de vue particulier sur plus de
200 images inédites dans ce genre
d'exposition ce qui est très bien c'est
que les gens qui viennent visiter cette
expo ont la chance de pouvoir discuter
avec tous les photographes
vous n'êtes pas obligé de mal avec les
mains dans l'eau regarder des choses
sans avoir d'avis particulier
là ça vous permet de savoir comment
s'est construit pourquoi avec quel type
de matériel
voilà ça peut amener une multitude de
discussions devraient échanger c'est une
agréable surprise pour nous de voir la
qualité de cette exposition
c'est la deuxième fois que je viens
cette exposition de photographes et
vraiment il ya de très belles heures des
univers variés apprécié du public venu
encore nombreux cette année ils sont
joueurs éducateurs ou tout simplement
passionnés de football et devant leur
téléviseur ou sur le terrain même ils
ont tous estimé un jour que l'arbitré
n'était pas bon des cartons jaunes
discutable un hors jeu inexistant sifflé
cette cinquantaine de phu tho suit une
formation pour prendre la relève des
hommes en noir savoir délivrer un carton
jaune se placer lors d'un coup de pied
arrêté des comportements qui peuvent
paraître parfois anodins pour les
joueurs mais qui sont en réalité
indispensable pour un arbitre de
football de son déplacement sur le
terrain peut dépendre le destin d'un
match
un arbitre aujourd'hui ne doit surtout
pas d'une influencé le score doit être
là pour protéger les joueurs
ça c'est clair parce que de nos jours la
plupart et au niveau où ils iront
arbitrons district les joueurs
travaillent le lendemain du match donc
pour ceux qui habitent le dimanche paul
lundi les gens travaillent malgré leur
passion pour le ballon rond cette
formation est l'occasion pour certains
de découvrir des règles inscrites dans
les 17 lois du jeu notamment pour le
frappeur d'un tir au but en cours de
match quand la balle touche le poteau
il n'a pas le droit de la récupérer ça
doit être si elle est remise en jeu
c'est de quelqu'un de son équipe qui
peut marquer mais lui il peut pas si la
balle touche le goal et que le goal la
repousse sur lui là il peut la rentrée
être arbitre c'est aussi une performance
physique au niveau de la ligue ile de
france les hommes en noir s'entraîne
trois fois par semaine la formation
terminée ces candidats auront le droit
de prendre le sifflet et du plaisir
d'une autre manière en gérant les 22
acteurs d'une rencontre on appréhende un
petit peu surtout au niveau senior dans
les petites divisions
dans les yvelines mais après les nous on
a des bons formateurs ici qui nous met
en confiance et justement travaillé ce
genre de situation car il pourrait y
avoir des débordements sur un match des
contestations de joueurs donc on nous
met déjà en condition et puis ben voila
je pense que ya toujours une première
fois à tout donc on verra bien sûr sur
le premier match
malgré les critiques dont fait l'objet
l'arbitrage aujourd'hui ils étaient 48 à
vouloir occuper ce poste sur le terrain
preuve que la passion est toujours plus
forte que les polémiques
ce week-end était organisé un stage
d'aïkido au dojo du gymnase des
pyramides à voisins-le-bretonneux
l'occasion de découvrir un art martial
méconnu et pourtant abordable à tous en
priorité aux seniors et aux femmes
créée en 1931 par le japonais mourier ou
chiba l'aïkido arrive en france dans les
années 50 dans cet art martial à la
différence du karaté ou du judo
le but n'est pas de combattre son
adversaire mais au contraire de guider
son agression pour l'annuler en pratique
l'attaquant appelé uk va tenter de
porter un coup aux défenseurs le tory ce
dernier va uniquement contrôlé
l'agression se servant de l'énergie de
l'attaquant sans jamais riposté et avec
ce principe de non opposition l'aïkido
est véritablement ouverts à tout type de
public de 6 ans jusqu'à la fin de sa vie
c'est un sport où on ne demande pas de
forces capables comme il n'ya pas de
position même si quelqu'un moi j'ai des
élèves qui font plus de 100 kilos et
j'ai des élèves femmes qui font 45 kg
elles peuvent se permettre de projeter
parce que elles vont aller dans le même
sens que cette agression
disons 100 kg + 45 ça fait 145 kg arr
intense mais non brutale l'aïkido permet
l'entretien du corps chez les seniors la
souplesse et l'énergie qu'ils requièrent
est aussi particulièrement adaptée aux
femmes des femmes chez qui l'aïkido peut
permettre de se sentir plus forte en cas
d'agression ça permet d'avoir une
attitude vis-à-vis de des relations
extérieures difficile d'être beaucoup
mieux poser dans cet automne dans son
corps et de ne pas avoir peur
inutilement en fait c'est souvent la
situation de peur de se
ce qui permet l'agression et donc si on
est solide de face à l'adversaire allait
de sa face à l'agresseur ça lui change
un petit peu son processus mental et
s'interroge donc à part attaquez vous
faire quelque chose aussi facilement si
vous souhaitez pratiquer l'aïkido les
inscriptions sont toujours ouvertes au
club de voisins-le-bretonneux mais avant
de devenir un uk ou un tory et de
revêtir la jupe noire le hakama vous
pouvez assister à un cours gratuitement
et posez vos questions au professeur
avant de faire votre choix
allez pour conclure cette émission
évidemment place à vos rendez-vous du
week-end tout d'abord il y aura de la
course de chiens de traîneaux
ce dimanche 1er décembre démonstration
comme chronométrés sur 10 km dans la
forêt de sainte apolline à plaisir aussi
dimanche à 11h30 descente du père noël
le vrai cette fois ci à maurepas juste à
côté de l'hôtel de ville
et pour terminer évidemment dans kiosque
que votre émission culture la semaine
prochaine aurélia de bissy vous
dévoilera la nouvelle programmation du
théâtre de la verrière pour ma part je
vous retrouverai dans le 7-8 sport avec
une interview exclusive de stéphane
paysans l'ancien entraîneur de nice
continue handball et une nouvelle
chroniqueuse très célèbre sur les pistes
d'athlétisme je ne vous en dis pas plus
d'ici là excellent week-end sur tv fille